look about Jared Kushner golden boy
Jared Kushner we've learned that this is
gonna sound weird Donald Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner is registered
to vote as a woman reporting on the
White House has become pretty difficult
to distinguish from satire and comedy
just sort of a reality at this point but
this is not a satirical story you'll
know of course that Donald Trump has
claimed voter fraud and voter
irregularities everything from people
registered twice which is an illegal
dead people voting undocumented
immigrants voting all of that stuff and
it turns out that lots of people
involved with Donald Trump are double
registered including his own daughter
Tiffany Trump but again that's not
actually against the law as long as you
only vote in one place and here's a
bizarre little wrinkle in this story
Donald Trump's son-in-law and very close
advisor Jared Kushner is registered to
vote as a woman and this actually
follows a trend not a gender related
trend this follows the trend of Jared
Kushner who seems to have a lot of
trouble filling out all sorts of forms
correctly you'll remember that his
disclosure forms were missing dozens of
meetings with foreign contacts for one
on those same forms he incorrectly
reported the dates that he was pursuing
his own graduate degree wasn't aware I
guess of when he was in graduate school
and according to the records held by the
New York State Board of Elections
Jared Cory Kushner is a woman and we've
got the voter registration up on the
screen for you
Jared C Kushner gender female all of a
sudden lock her up has taken on a
drastically different meaning huh now
straight up if Jared Kushner identifies
as a woman I have no problem with that I
mean period right . i have no problem
with Jared Kushner identifying a woman
if he does how soon will Trump ists all
of a sudden be bragging about how they
support trans rights because they
support Jared Kushner being in Donald
Trump's administration but of course
that's insane right my understanding and
I'm guessing your understanding is that
Jared Kushner identifies as a man so
what we have here is a situation where
the guy who was supposedly going to
single-handedly solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict didn't
check
got the right box for gender on his own
voter registration this guy is supposed
to be one of the best smart people that
Donald Trump is going to put around
himself now we don't really know for
sure what the explanation is Wired
magazine uncovered this they've not
received a comment from Jared Kushner
about it and these little individual
idiocy czar funny but they actually
connect to really serious issues Donald
Trump is spending millions of dollars on
this voter fraud Commission trying to
justify his absurd suggestion that in
reality he won the popular vote in 2016
not Hillary Clinton partially because
three to five million people voted
illegally that's a claim there's no
evidence for period the more we look
into it the more it seems that it's
people who died but didn't actually vote
that are just on the voter rolls since
they were dead they didn't actually vote
it seems like it's clerical errors but
meanwhile more and more people
associated with Donald Trump Trump's
family Trump's adviser Steve Bannon
registered to vote in multiple locations
other staff they are actually guilty of
the actions that Donald Trump is
claiming flipped the popular vote to
Hillary Clinton but the important thing
is he's spending millions of your
dollars on this nonsense call your local
elected officials and just demand that
Trump cut it out as Hillary Clinton is
famous for saying because this is a
waste of money and it is a waste of time
and it provides political cover for
Trump and other Republicans to pass
really really destructive bills the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad